mais voilà
le capitaine
[Applaudissements]
et bakkies botha rosie volt
va dit
ces deux robes de bal
[Applaudissements]
m
diva la roue mon père a dit reconnaître
le talent et les chérir
demandé chacun votre tour de dire un
petit truc pour les femmes aujourd'hui
aller pour son retour lui demandait
isabelle aller comme ça on sait pouvait
être coupé ça m'arrange
vous savez quoi j'en suis encore une ce
temps que c'est une bonne définition de
la femme une quoi
il ya des gens d'autres innovant turcs
leaders est avec le coupé pendant que la
phrase non mais c'est la vraie phrase
willy bernard montiel alors moi j'ai
envie de dire je suis une femme et pas
que le 8 mars d'accord pas mal d'efforts
sonic
bah oui y'a pas que 8 mars alors moi
j'ai une pensée aujourd'hui pour toutes
les femmes qui ne peuvent pas s'exprimer
et qui peuvent s'y et qui par
l'intermédiaire de ceux qui ont la
possibilité de le faire compte sur nous
pour qu'on puisse défendre leurs droits
et on ne fait pas simplement les femmes
pour les femmes mais tous ensemble les
hommes et les femmes en ce sens que ce
n'est pas un combat féminin c'est un
combat de des hommes et des femmes
ensemble main dans la main oui
labossière de dire des baleines
[Rires]
je regarde la caméra le père noël
est perdu avec s'est fait dépouiller
alors beaucoup mes petits chats j'espère
que vous allez bien
vous dire que j'aime toutes les femmes
tous les hommes et tous les gens non
bières et non j'aurais comme moi ne
changeait pas croyez en vous bisous
[Applaudissements]
mais moi j'ai des messages beaucoup plus
intéressant
ça va un petit peu on en est oui alors
oui ah bah moi titre intime et
personnelle j'ai j'ai toujours eu lieu
autour de moi que des femmes parce que
j'ai envie de perdre donc j'ai une mère
extraordinaire une grand mère
extraordinaire aujourd'hui une fille des
amis mais j'ai jamais eu autant besoin
d'hommes aujourd'hui que pour les
penguins
moi j'aimerais embrasser toutes les
femmes que je n'ai pas encore rencontré
[Applaudissements]
pas compris que c'était une chance pour
elle
[Rires]
mais ce mât à l'éthique et que serait
l'homme sur la femme
[Applaudissements]
mais là c'est la genèse de l'humanité la
femme est extraordinaire la femme est
douce gentille affectueuse que serait un
homme sans une femme c'est très
important il faut se poser les bonnes
questions la femme c'est tout pour la
vie c'est tout pour le monde et c'est
tout pour chaque personne d'entre nous
je vous présentais comme ici
allez c'est important qu'un cocu nous
parle des femmes etc et
les femmes sont merveilleuses les femmes
autour du plateau sont fantastiques les
femmes dans le public toutes les femmes
qui nous regardent les femmes sont au
soleil elles sont celles de la vie sans
elle on s'ennuie